this 1800 GMT and we begin this NewsHour
with the European citizens that are
being flown home from Niger following
the coup there last week
the French government is currently
evacuating uh organizing hundreds of
passport holders to leave the country
the operation began after attacks on the
French Embassy in the capital nyame and
the closure of niger's borders just days
after the president Mohammed bazoom was
deposed in a coup Victoria getting B
begins our coverage
Naomi the first French citizens arrive
ahead of their evacuation flights home
many Nigerians say they're pleased
French people are leaving the country
as an African I can say that all the
problems that Africans are experiencing
in Niger and in Africa it's France
that's at the root of our suffering
we've seen the example of Malian Burkina
Faso so we too are going to follow in
their footsteps all France has to do is
to leave
diplomats in Paris have been working
around the clock to evacuate citizens
from Niger after president Muhammad
bazoom was deposed last week
Niger is one of the world's poorest
countries and relies heavily on
financial support from Western backers
and the regional block ecowas
most of that Aid has been frozen because
of the coup the military rulers in
neighboring Mali and Burkina Faso have
criticized the funding freeze saying the
poorest will be hit hardest French
troops were ordered to leave Mali
recently refused applications
we refuse to apply these illegal
illegitimate and inhumane sanctions
against the people of Niger we warn that
any military intervention against nizir
will be considered as a declaration of
war against Burkina Faso and Mali
before the coup Niger was an important
Ally of the West in the fight against
armed groups linked to al-Qaeda in the
Sahel
it's also one of the world's biggest
producers of uranium which fuels nuclear
power stations
Niger produced more than 2 000 tons of
high-grade uranium last year that's five
percent of global output France is
heavily reliant on nuclear energy Niger
supplies an estimated 15 percent of
uranium for French nuclear power
stations the French government says that
it has two years worth of uranium stocks
some analysts say Western powers are
only interested in niger's natural
resources it's very worrisome and I
think all Africans must be very worried
or concerned that France is making
itself has made itself a former colonial
power a king maker in Africa and chooses
to protect its interests even if that
means removing African leaders
the leaders of the coup have announced
the suspension of uranium exports to
France and other European countries and
are warning the west and ecowas not to
order a military intervention
Victoria Gayton B Al Jazeera
an advisor to the post president has
been speaking to Al Jazeera Eros Sani
says the ousted government would support
military intervention by ecowas to
reinstate the president but denies
allegations they're discussing military
action with France he spoke to my
colleague Sami zedan via WhatsApp
resolution of this conflict is all what
everyone is hoping in this country and
nobody really wishes to see a Bloodshed
or really a violent conflict
bursting in our country but all depends
on the Junta who sees the Power by force
and is helding and hostage our president
and is using violence to
uh
to attack our people who are trying to
demonstrate their this appropriation of
what they are doing and that who are
showing that they are not they don't
agree with the coup uh there's violence
that's going on many of our
political members are
under arrest this is the violence that
they are using so we wish that the
wellness may not burst into our country
but the behavior of the Junta who sees
the power is leading to violence in this
country do you support military
intervention of any kind to try and
reinstate the president
in the protocol of the ecowas there is
the possibility of using
violence against
any power that is trying to use violence
to seize the power in in skechos country
so it's not a matter of if we support or
not but we are uh
saying that if Echo has tried to use
violence it it is not illegal because
there are these protocol
that are in the ecowas uh
Amendment so we cannot be against a
course because we are a member of the
ecowas and everything that Echoes
decides to do is okay for us because we
are members and we support the equals
authorities have you been in touch with
the French about French military
intervention
we we have not been in chat with French
about their intervention their military
intervention and we are not in touch
with France uh concerning their
intervention in the military
Frenchies in contact with one of our
leaders who is trying to negotiate with
the Junta that's all we know and that's
all I know but we don't have any
connection with the French about their
military intervention
all right let's bring an ufflesing who's
the head of the Sahel program at the
German peace organization the Conrad
adanauer Foundation he joins us live
from bamako a very warm welcome to you
sir the regional block echoas as we
heard there the economic community of
West African states have told the coup
leaders Point Blank reinstate the
democratically elected president or run
the risk of force how seriously should
we take that threat
I think it's an empty thread I mean if
you want to intervene militarily you
need someone supporting you on the
ground but Mr bazoom has been under
house arrest you know for almost a week
now and no army unit has come to his
rescue so it's unlikely that uh you know
a military intervention Force you know
would work if you're flying and you know
Plane full of of soldiers and you know
that make your way to the presidential
Palace without any support on the ground
I mean ecowas has intervened before 2017
in Gambia but then they were really
invited by the government but that's not
the case here I mean the consequence of
military intervention could mean a
pretty serious Showdown are you
suggesting that's extremely unlikely to
happen
yeah I mean the states are High I mean
e-commerce basically make this right now
but they're unlikely to follow up and I
think this threat has made also you know
the butchers you know you know it's hard
in their stance really to to stay you
know in power and they will use this to
to mobilize the street this week again
to you know frame as someone being you
know I mean played into cozy if it's a
foreigner so no one to rescue him
um how wary given all the other options
the other levers the echoas and indeed
Western Powers could pull how wary
should we be about the decision by
several powers to Halt Aid to the
country a country where of course 40 of
the population depends upon foreign help
yeah that's it's really Horizon but also
the example of Mali or Burkina Faso you
know shows us where also age was
suspended you know you know they didn't
stop military governments from from
doing doing what they want to do
sanctions always you know or you know
substantial Aid always hits the wrong
people but it it really really affects
decision makers you're trying to Target
now we've been looking at pictures over
the past few hours of foreign Nationals
packing up their belongings and fleeing
the country gathering at the airport of
course for many Nigerians they have very
few choices for them if things become
more volatile are we looking at a
potential Refugee crisis here
well I think the Western countries are
trying to get their citizens out as you
know hopes are fading of some kind of
cool being reversed and they don't want
to have the same situation like in Sudan
where they really struggle to outlive
people for African countries really it's
it's difficult like Nigerians going to
uh trying to to other countries I mean
the the road is out of the capital is
dangerous anyway but yeah definitely
more Nigerians will seek you know
shelter abroad if only to seek work
because no you know there are few
opportunities with this uh you know
crisis you know ngos packing up less
AIDS so there will be more migrant
movements towards neighboring countries
for sure
and when you say neighboring countries
of course we're talking about Libya uh
to the north aren't we and of course the
southern European states have struggled
with uh refugees clearly desperately
trying to make the crossing across the
Mediterranean and dying in the process
yeah absolutely in Niger I mean the
previous government was this kind of
stop gap of the migration route from
from Niger via Libya to the coast and
you know that that was why Euros in the
Europe in the first place was interested
in you know working with Niger not so
much security do you have this this is a
local issue but they really wanted to to
close the my main migration route from
Niger to to Libya now their Europe is in
a very vulnerable position because uh I
mean the you know this decision to close
the route was very unpopular many people
lost jobs in Nigeria not just Smugglers
also people who own hotels drivers
restaurants who are accommodating you
know migrants so there's really no
pressure on the new government to you
know from from locals and agates and the
north to reopen the the road to to Libya
and this is uh that will be a huge
challenge for Europe right-wing parties
now on the rise because of growing
migration and um before you go I just
want your sense on how genuine we you
think this apparent anti-french and
pro-russian sentiment is obviously we've
seen a lot of flag waving on our screens
in the Army in the capital clearly the
Optics of all of this matters right now
but in the early hours after the coup
there are initially lots of people on
the streets out defending the outside
president so what's going on here
I mean it has been always a lingering
anti-funish sentiment like in other
saving countries like Mali in Nigeria
because you know French are just
unpopular for many reasons most
importantly being the former colonial
power yes there was on the first day
some small protests which was basically
a gun down and now the supporters of
Kazuma saying indoors were those the
loudest voices and willing to carry
Russian Flags they're going to the
street if you look at the demonstrations
the pictures you often see the Russian
flag is is turned upside down that's
because they're basically these flags
are distributed to people you know who
don't know Russia anyway but are willing
to you know don't like France so they
see it you know have this illusion that
Russia is something better than France
and then they're waving the Russian flag
but
well I mean it's not a real for Russia
sentiment it's just groups supporting
the yunta aware of who are now basically
exploiting you know I mean the anger and
by Distributing Russian flags and you
know you know supporting the the
military government
so I flew it in extremely unpredictable
situation there in Nigeria at the moment
of Lessing from the Conrad Adenauer
Foundation many thanks